Congress of Vienna was sort of an
all-star negotiating event it was the
first major get-together of all of the
heads of Europe at the end of the
Napoleonic Wars Europe had been turned
totally upside-down by Napoleon and the
heads of Europe got together to redraw
the borders France of course had just
been defeated and Frances foreign
minister was able to pull off one of the
greatest negotiating upsets in history
by using a division between the
victorious Allies to reinsert himself as
a major player and secure france's
stature on the world stage is often a
weaker party can capitalize on divisions
or differences of interest between the
the other counterparties what the French
Foreign Minister did and something that
we can use and take advantage of in our
everyday lives is he saw that the other
people across the table had different
interests from each other
and when their division became apparent
he realized that he could throw his
weight to one side or the other and tip
the balance in their favor that gave him
tremendous leverage which he used to his
advantage
division and you see this in politics
occasionally as well the person who
throws their weight and tips the balance
gets a great deal of power and and and
even someone who starts out at a
disadvantage can multiply their their
their leverage that way I mean generally
the last congressman or senator to sign
on to a vote that's very close to
passing is able to get all sorts of
benefits and and and goodies out of it
because his vote becomes the necessary
vote to cross the line you see that all
the time
some people think that you should that
the smart ploy is to wait until the very
last moment until they really need your
vote before before making your move if
that's your game then then sure